♪ ♪
>> Jessica: FOX NEWS ALERT
ELON MUSK OFFICIALLY TERMINATED
$44 MILLION DEAL TO BUY TWITTER.
ELONVA SAID TWITTER HAS
MISREPRESENTED HISPANIC ACCOUNTS
AND THE TWITTER DID NOT PROVIDE
RELATIVE BUSINESS INFORMATION HE
REQUESTED.
SO, JUDGE JEANINE, YOU THOUGHT
THIS WAS A BIG TROLL FROM THE
BEGINNING?
>> Jessica: I HOPE YOU GUYS
AGREE AS WELL.
OVERALL, IT SEEMS LIKE NO ONE
WANTS TWITTER AND ELON MUSK, YOU
KNOW WANTED TO GET INTO THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS.
AT ONE POINT, HE WANTED IT BUT
THEN HE SAW WHAT HAPPENED AT
TESLA ON THE OTHER SIDE, THIS IS
ACTUALLY A LOT MORE VALUABLE
THAN THE PUBLIC SQUARE AS IT
WERE.
THIS BELIEF INTO DILIGENT AND
NOT GETTING THE INFORMATION YOU
WANTED WHEN YOU WAIVE DILIGENCE
IN THE FIRST PLACE WRINKLED AND
I THINK HE'S HAD SEVERAL WEEKS,
MONTHS OF BAD PRESS.
IT WILL JUST GO AWAY FROM ALL OF
THIS AND GO BACK TO BUILDING
ROCKETS AND COOL CARS.
>> Katie: GREG, PEOPLE AT
TWITTER HEADQUARTERS HAPPY OR
SAD?
>> Greg: THE REASON HE IS THE
RICHEST PERSON ON EARTH HE FINDS
MORE THAN ONE WAY TO WIN.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IF HE BUYS TWITTER HE WINS BUT
IF HE DOESN'T BITE, HE STILL
WON.
HE DID A NUMBER OF THINGS, HE
EXPOSED TO JUST FALLACIES ABOUT
TWITTER BEING FAIR, TWITTER
BEING FREE.
HE IS AN ENGINEER.
HE WENT IN AND KICKED THE TIRES,
LOOKED UNDER THE HOOD AND
EVERYBODY ELSE TAKE A LOOK AT IT
AT THE SAME TIME.
SO BASICALLY, HE WAS A BULL IN A
CHINA SHOP.
BUT HE WAS AN ENGINEER AND A
HE SHOWED WHAT IS IN THERE
BROKEN.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M KIND OF
SAD BECAUSE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
FUN.
AT THE SAME TIME, I LEARNED A
LOT, YOU KNOW.
I HOPE WE CAN STILL BE FRIENDS.
>> Katie: JUDGE, THE MARKET IS
CLOSED RIGHT NOW.
BUT DO YOU THINK THIS WILL TANK
TWITTER'S STOCK ON MONDAY?
>> Judge Jeanine: I REALLY DO.
I'M DISAPPOINTED, LIKE GREG, I
REALLY AM SURE TO LIKE THE IDEA
OF SOMEONE COMING IN AND TALKING
ABOUT FREE SPEECH AND TELLING
PEOPLE, YOU WILL NOT HAVE A
CRYING ROOM ANYMORE.
SOMEONE WHO WAS FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE KNEW A MONTH
AGO AND MORE THAN A MONTH AGO,
THERE WAS AN ISSUE WITH THE SPAM
IN ALL OF THIS STUFF.
IT WAS A GREATER THAN 5%?
AND DOES IT APPEAR THAT TWITTER
TO IDENTIFY OR GIVE THE
INFORMATION NEEDED?
AND SO, YOU KNOW, AS GREG SAID
THE ANALOGY LOOKED UNDER THE
HOOD.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ALLOWED
THEM TO REALLY LOOK UNDER THE
HOOD.
THE QUESTION IS, IS HE BEING A
SANCTION NOW?
DOES HE LOSE MONEY AND IS THERE
PENALTY MONEY IN THERE AND
AUTOMATICALLY IF HE DOESN'T GO
FORWARD?
WHY ARE YOU SHOWING ME THAT?
>> Greg: IT IS A QUESTION FOR
FAN MAIL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Katie: IT'S NOT WORTH
ANYTHING IS THE QUESTION.
>> Joey: DON'T PUT A
BILLIONAIRE OR POLITICIAN, THEY
DON'T SAVE THE BIG DAY.
THE THING THAT IS FISHY ABOUT
THIS, -- EVEN THE RHETORIC, DID
HE THINK HE HAD INSIDE
INFORMATION AND THOUGHT HE
CALCULATED BUT NOW THAT'